So, are we happy with our Fried Python? Writing the code that we did, answering
the last question. And if you're becoming a tasteful programmer, which I hope
all of you are, you should be recoiling in horror with what we just did and
smoke should be coming out of your ears. Anytime you see a lot of cutting and
pasting or copying code like this. That should raise alarm bells, if not, make
smoke come out of your ears, literally. And it should tell you that there's
something really bad about the abstractions you have. Previously, we've seen
this with procedures. If we had a lot of copies of code that were doing the same
thing or very close to the same thing, what we should do is take all those, turn
them into a procedure and maybe have a parameter that generates the slightly
different behaviors that we needed. This was procedural abstraction, a way to
reuse code by using procedures and to use parameters to specialize the behavior.
That's not quite what we need here, what we need is a similar kind of
abstraction that works on types.